this is georgetown capital of british
guiana on the northern coast of south
america
it is populated by the descendants of
african east indian portuguese chinese
europeans and south american indians
the commercial center of georgetown lies
close to the waterfront
here are modern buildings department
stores and supermarkets
there are also churches
and cinemas
the coastal railroad parallels the
coastal highway running eastward from
georgetown
another paved highway runs 25 miles
south to atkinson airfield
british guyana has an agricultural
economy chiefly sugar and rice
the industrious viennese tend their
farms well
this is a native rice plantation
fishing is popular and productive and
helps to vary the diet
in the american indian villages women
make bread and many dishes from cassava
their staple food
local high schools prepare students for
university entrance and a national
university is being established
the people of british guiana are great
sports enthusiasts
if these people were deprived of the use
of their limbs they would not only be
denied much pleasure but they could no
longer tend their farms or make a living
that is why it is so important that they
understand british guiana's crippling
disease salaria
malaria or filariasis is carried by
mosquitoes and may lead to swelling of
the legs arms and other parts of the
body after years of repeated infection
the disease is more often seen in
females because their legs are exposed
before a swelling appears the blood of
the infected person contains young
embryo worms called microfilari
these microfilarii can be seen in the
infected person's blood only at night
when a female filaria mosquito feeds on
infected person's blood it sucks up
these microfilari which then pass into
the stomach of the mosquito
in the mosquito stomach the micropolaria
remains active for a short while then
bores through the wall of the stomach
and moves to the thorax or chest region
of the mosquito
in a muscle fiber of the thorax the
young larva grows short and thick until
it becomes shaped like a sausage
then it enters into the second stage and
gradually grows longer and narrower
until it becomes an infective larva
it wriggles its way from the thorax to
the head of the mosquito and enters the
proboscis or beak
when the infected mosquito bends down to
bite again the infective larva crawls
out of the proboscis and drops onto the
skin of the person being bitten
then it goes into the skin and travels
around the person's body
in about a year it becomes a sexually
mature male or female worm
the worms mate and the eggs develop into
a microfilarii which appear in the
person's blood
thus completing the cycle
one of the main methods of detecting
whether one has malaria before the
swelling appears is by making a blood
smear
blood is taken from a finger at night
early in the morning the microfilaria go
deep into the body
if there is at least one microfilaria
present the person is said to have
positive blood
if his blood is negative it does not
necessarily mean that he is free of
infection
this is because the worms may have
entered the person's body recently and
are not sure enough to produce the micro
polarity
also when a person already has a
swelling his blood is usually negative
there are many effects of filaria
long-standing infection may lead to
swelling of the limbs called
elephantiasis
at first tissue fluid or lymph
accumulates but later there are
permanent changes in the tissues
themselves
the disease cripples physically mentally
economically and socially
the most damaging effect is felt by the
wage earner and his family
a job is not readily given to a person
who has elephantiasis if he has to stay
on his feet all day long
young girls having elephantiasis usually
are denied romance and marriage because
of their permanently swollen limbs
the depressive state which this disease
leads to is one of its most damaging
effects
if he does have a job he has to carry
out his duties the best he can even with
his legs swollen
convinced that something could be done
about the valeria problem the
governments of british guiana and the
united states of america have been
working together to solve it
on april 29 1961 representatives of the
ministry of health and the united states
agency for international development
agreed to finance a joint solarisis
research and control project this
project comes under the technical
assistance development organization
abbreviated as tado
the united states government has
supplied money equipment and three
experts
a medical entomologist who studies the
mosquitoes in order to determine which
ones transmit filariasis from person to
person
a parasitologist who studies the
parasites or worms which cause the
disease
and a health educator who informs the
public concerning the disease and
secures their cooperation while control
measures are being undertaken
the ministry of health has long worked
to control philosophy
in 1955 an energetic doctor began a
countrywide campaign to control disease
this campaign was carried out for about
six years prior to the present joint
program
in the filariasis clinics d's doctors
studied increase or decrease in size of
limbs by displacement of water
the patient steps into a water-filled
drum
water comes out of the spout and is
measured
blood tests are also taken at night in
the filariasis clinics so that the
patient's case history will be complete
clinics are held not only in georgetown
but also in the coastal villages having
much filariasis
in the headquarters building of the
filariasis research and control unit
there are offices and laboratories for
entomology parasitology clinical and
health education sections
the united states medical entomologist
has trained viennese personnel in many
aspects of etymological work with
valeria mosquitoes both in the field and
the laboratory
the united states parasitologist has
trained guianese in taking blood smears
and identification of filaria parasites
found in the smears
a typical filarial area along the east
coast including buxton and surroundings
was selected as the first area for
working the techniques of controlling
the filaria mosquitoes and the paleria
worms
the health education section of the
filariasis unit has prepared pamphlets
and posters for educating the public
concerning the nature and cause of
filariasis and how the public can
cooperate to help control the disease
lectures conferences and discussions are
held just before the night blood survey
teams visit a valeria area
after the health educators have paved
the way the night blood survey teams go
from house to house in the palarial
villages and take a blood smear on each
member of every family
this provides important basic
information as to the number of persons
having young palarial worms in their
blood
in the interior of british guiana the
native indians have two other types of
filariasis which do not result in
swellings
blood surveys among these indians can be
held in the day because the microfilaria
are present in the blood at all times
the blood smears are taken to the
parasitology laboratory where they are
stained so that the worm-like
microfilaria can be easily seen
each morning entomology field teams
spend the first two working hours in
collecting adult and aquatic stages of
mosquitoes
all kinds of mosquitoes are collected in
order to determine how many different
kinds are carrying the filarial worms
inside houses filaria mosquitoes are
found mostly on walls and on hanging
objects such as clothing curtains and
mosquito nets
they are also found on or under
furniture and in empty containers or
receptacles
the mosquitoes are sucked into a
collecting tube and transferred to cages
another type of filaria mosquito is
usually found in bushy areas
in the coastal trains mosquitoes can
easily be transported for many miles
in british guiana drums containing water
are a second source of breeding of the
main filaria mosquito which is called
culex
the filaria mosquito also breeds in
large tanks some of which are
inaccessible for control work
in this country the main filaria
mosquito breeds in drains only when they
have become contaminated with waste
the female culex mosquito lays its eggs
on the surface of the water they are
cemented together to form a small raft
about one eighth of an inch long
a single dip into a latrine will often
yield hundreds of worm-like larvae and
comma-shaped pupia of culex the adult
mosquito emerges from the pupa dries
itself and flies away
it usually takes only seven to ten days
for the complete development from the
egg to the adult
the water stages of the second kind of
filaria mosquito which is called
mansonia are found associated with
certain water plants especially the
water lettuce
the man sonia larvae and pupae cannot
breathe the air at the surface of the
water like culex
instead they attach themselves to roots
and leaves of water plants which have
air cavities and suck up the oxygen
which they need
the larvae feed while hanging from their
place of attachment
the culex mosquito can be controlled in
two ways
first pit latrines are sprayed with gas
oil
only one such spraying is needed each
month to prevent breeding of the culex
mosquito
each time the lactrine is sprayed it is
marked with paint this provides a record
of the number of times the laptine has
been sprayed
the easiest way to control valeria
mosquito breeding in drums is to empty
them and keep them turned upside down
when water is not being stored
if it is necessary to store up water a
tight fitting drum cover should be made
of wood or metal it should be tightly
replaced after each time that water is
drawn from the drum
the cover should be solid if the drum is
not kept under a drain pipe
if it is kept under a pipe the hole in
the center of the cover should be
covered with a fine screen in order to
prevent the mosquito from laying its
eggs on the water
there should be no gap or hole
whatsoever in the fitted cover
sleeping under a mosquito net will
prevent the mosquito from sucking
infected blood or depositing malaria
worms on the skin
the most important means of controlling
filariasis is by giving out a drug
called genocide or heterozyme
when taken is directed this drug kills
the microfilarii in the blood
in british guiana a single course of
treatment is taken over a period of
seven days in gradually increasing
dosages
after the first day while the drug is
acting on the
the person may not feel well in spite of
this he should continue with the full
treatment because the illness indicates
that the drug is killing the worms in
the blood
after the very active microfilaria are
killed the blood becomes free of filaria
worms the valeria mosquitoes cannot then
pick up the worms while feeding on this
person
the control of malaria cannot be done in
a short time
it involves much cooperation between the
public and health personnel
if each person who is given the drug
takes it in full without fail then
elephantiasis will become a thing of the
past
the worms in the blood will be killed
and the mosquito will not be able to
pass them on to another person when the
night blood collecting teams come to
your house cooperate with them and let
them take blood from your fingers
don't let yourself become deprived of
the use of your legs you can avoid
becoming crippled by valeria
take the advice of the health
authorities who have been doing their
utmost to help eliminate this crippling
scourge
you